bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi elle 5
janvier
ils sont supposés être les moins fort en
mai ils croient en l'exploit les
footballeurs de houille joue ce week-end
les 32e de finale de la coupe de france
un exploit pour le club yvelinois qui
endossera pour l'occasion un maillot
spécial celui du petit poucet 80 km
heure au lieu de 90 des pv de
stationnement plus cher hausse du prix
des péages prime à la casse élargi la
nouvelle année apporte son lot de
changements pour les automobilistes et
provoque la colère des associations
daniel kérou est notre invité fil rouge
pour cette émission le président de 40
millions d'automobilistes dans le reste
de l'actualité retour sur la tempête
eleanor qui a causé des dégâts dans les
yvelines ou encore les voeux des saint
quentinois pour la nouvelle année
c'est le match à ne pas manquer ce
week-end en football en coupe de france
de football ou de clubs de régionale 3
es défiera ce samedi dans son stade
concarneau un club qui évolue en
national cinq divisions au dessus des
deux équipes ce jeudi soir laisse les
joueurs ont reçu un maillot spécial avec
la mention petit poucet de la
compétition reportage de michael et demi
dont où il est officiellement le petit
poucet de la coupe de france de football
à moins de 48 heures de son 32e de
finale contre l'équipe de concarneau et
joueurs qui évoluent en régionale 3 ont
reçu de la part des sponsors des maillot
collector symbole sur le terrain du
statut de plus petites équipes engagées
dans la compétition
je crois que c'est un système de points
ces faits au nombre de surprises réalisé
pour l'arrivée jusque là nous avons
éliminé trois équipes qui étaient deux
divisions au dessus
et il semble que nous ayons donc mérité
une fois les maillots distribuer les
joueurs se sont rendus directement stade
maurice baquet futur théâtre de ce 32e
de finale pour effectuer un dernier
entraînement
[Musique]
l'occasion pour l'entraîneur de rassurer
ses joueurs avant ce match historique
l'équipe de cours carlo évolué cinq
divisions dessus des yvelinois ont joué
une montagne voulait qu'on pourquoi
voulait construire son risque rien et on
part en part en part de loin on est très
loin de de concarneau je voulais je vous
dise de plus soit pas se mettre la
pression
on est très loin de concarneau c'est une
grosse grosse équipe voulez que je vous
dise quoi de plus on se prépare on se
fait plaisir et on verra bien toute
façon on n'a rien à perdre pour créer
l'exploit les ivy loi pourront compter
sur le soutien du public plus de 2000
spectateurs sont attendus dans les
gradins coup d'envoi 15 heures ce samedi
6 janvier et bonne chance du coup à eux
pour ce week-end nous reviendrons sur ce
match lundi dans notre journal
attention si vous empruntez la ligne l
du transilien ce week-end le trafic sera
perturbé samedi et dimanche aucun train
ne circulera entre les gares de
versailles chantiers et paris
montparnasse
en cause des travaux à hauteur de
clamart dans le cadre du grand paris
express pour vous rendre ou revenir de
paris vous pourrez néanmoins emprunté
les lignes u et c'est plus
d'informations et de précisions sur le
site internet transilien.com des
difficultés dans les transports en
commun et 2
nombreux changements sur la route avec
notamment la polémique qui enfle sur la
vitesse maximale pour les routes
secondaires selon toute vraisemblance le
gouvernement devrait annoncer mercredi
prochain une baisse de la vitesse de 90
à 80 avec km/heure un changement auquel
s'opposent elles l'association 40
millions d'automobilistes daniel
guerreau bonsoir oui bonsoir vous êtes
le président de cette association
expliquez nous pourquoi vous vous êtes
contre cette probable décision la
décision définitive sera prise mercredi
pourquoi vous êtes contre ça semble
pourtant au prime abord comme ça un
petit peu logique de vouloir baisser la
vitesse pour vouloir baisser le nombre
de morts
c'est mardi à 16h que ce parti est pas
mercredi
merci pour la précision la première le
conseil interministériel à la sécurité
routière qui devrait prendre cette
décision puisque on sait qu'elle est
pratiquement actée j'ai été reçu hier
soir à matignon
je suis venu dire au conseiller du
premier ministre que finalement nous
sommes les porte parole des
automobilistes et que finalement
pourquoi nous sommes content ce sont les
automobilistes qui sommes qui sont
contre ils sont contre trois
automobilistes sur quatre sont contre
cette mesure parce qu'il ne la
comprennent pas parce qu'autour de nous
vous regardez il ya une expérimentation
qui a été fait pour démontrer que si on
réduit de 90 à 80 on va réduire de 300
morts cette extrapolation était fait à
partir d'une hta théorème dit de neilson
qui a été déclinée ya 40 ans dont on se
sert d'ailleurs à peu près qu'en france
mais ça c'est de la pure mathématiques
et théorie nous on a été voir ce qui se
passait au danemark le danemark ivoula
qui sont passés de 80 ils sont passés de
80 90
on a été voir on a interrogé les gens là
bas et ils nous ont dit mais parce qu'on
dit toujours les français ne respectent
rien on s'est aperçus qu'au danemark
ben les gens au lieu de rouler à 80 il
roulait à plus de 80 85 voix 86-87
d'autres qui roulait moins de 80 points
qu'ils avaient peur et rouler à 70 au
milieu il y avait des caméras donc
cibler les gens commençaient à s'énerver
doublé et les accidents le céleri ce que
vous dites vous c'est que les gens
roulent moins vite et que d'autres
veuillent les doubles
sa place mais chassez conservant soit
conduit à céder ce sont des faits c'est
pas une formule mathématique et donc il
ya eu quand on a passé ses routes ses
tronçons de route de 84 à 90 on a
constaté qu'il avait triste non ça
n'améliore pas la sécurité de baisser la
vitesse sur la salle las vegas et non
non et on a été voir en haute-saône là
où monsieur cazeneuve à juste titre
avait dit devant les polémiques il y
avait des gens qui voulaient b c et c
ayant fait que meriem en taisant 2014
2015 à 2017
donc on n'était pas ce qui se passait en
haute saône on a déjà vu que les routes
avaient été élargies de 1,5 mètre de
chaque côté ensuite qu'on avait refait
les marquages il 16 millions de travaux
donc on commence à comparer au bout de
l'avion il faudrait peut-être plus faire
de travaux sur en plus je vais maintenir
le raison plutôt que de vouloir laisser
là h la vitesse tous les riverains nous
ont dit c'est pire qu'avant ils viennent
de le phénomène que je viens de vous
décrire se passe là bas ça veut dire que
les gens respectent pas d'autres
respecte les camions double et il ya des
accidents
alors vous voulez vous faire réagir sur
un argument de votre association aussi
qui peut paraître étonnant comme ça ont
gelé vue sur votre site internet vous
dites que c'est aussi éventuellement si
on baisse la vitesse un handicap pour
l'économie des régions les plus
enclavées
est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer un
petit peu ça est-ce que ça va jouer pour
vous par exemple sur la région bretagne
le fait qu'on baisse la vitesse quand
les gens donc que des routes secondaires
ou nationale puisqu'elle était nationale
sont concernées sont celles qui ont un
terre-plein central mais les autres sont
conscients des ce qui veut dire que dans
les régions qui ont des routes normales
nationales et départementales et
communales la vitesse va être abaissée
donc ils vont perdre du temps moi
j'écris ma banquière qui me disait quand
je vais les atours je vais perdre du
temps alors vous êtes obligé de prendre
l'autoroute peut-être maintenant qu'il
augmentait encore en plus voyez donc on
est effectivement là encore en train de
prendre des champs ou politique pour
plaire à la populace kruth et c'est vrai
que depuis quatre ans la mortalité a
augmenté ou oui les chiliens sont pas
très bons
il ya beaucoup plus de vélos et de
piétons qui se sont tués mais automobile
c'est donc la mentalité n'a pas baissé
comme le ps avant donc le gouvernement
dit il faut marquer les esprits et il a
pris cette mesure
qui est une mesure qu'on voit bien qu'il
commence à soulève les débats pour dire
on va faire quelque chose s'est passé de
mesures là qui va changer les choses
donc là je dis c'est plutôt une décision
politique et quand on a une décision
politique on ne peut pas au projet
d'arguments rationnels
alors ces quatre cent mille kilomètres
aujourd'hui en france qui sont à 90
km/heure vous disiez ne seront pas
toutes concernées celles qui n'ont pas
de terre-plein central vous le disiez
vous même les questions vous avez été
reçu jeudi par à matignon justement est
ce que vous sentez que vos arguments
sont écoutés qu'on pourrait avoir une
surprise entre guillemets mardi que
finalement le gouvernement n'annonce pas
que je la donnerai et sbs c'est frais ça
m'étonnerait tout est prêt on le sait il
ya même eu les arguments qui ont été
diffusés dans les différentes
préfectures sont les conseils que j'ai
rencontrés étaient quand même à l'écouté
il y en a qui m'a dit écoutez c'est
peut-être pas irréversible voilà et moi
j'ai dit pourquoi j'ai un argument qui
est fort j
ce qui est compris par les
automobilistes moduler la vitesse c'est
compris la généraliser une vitesse je
n'ai pas compris
vous voulez dire que selon les routes ce
lieu les toits rouges et
d'automobilistes quand vous êtes sur une
droite qui a personne on vous dit de
rouler à 80 vous comprenez pas par
contre le 80 sur des routes de corse
c'est déjà trop oui donc moi quand j'ai
passé mon permis pour des on a appris et
on m'a dit qu'il fallait que j'adapte
mon comportement à mon environnement à
mon environnement routier au climat etc
donc si on sent qu'on n'est pas en
danger on entend ça les pluies ont
adapté la vitesse à la route c'est
compris généralisée des vitesses tout
les mêmes quelle que soit la route ça
n'est pas compris aujourd'hui le
gouvernement dit que ça pourrait
permettre de sauver 300 à 400 vies par
an vous contestez une expérience aucune
expérience de démontre c'est un théorème
encore comme je voulais dit de nielsen
qui est un théorème mathématique basées
sur des statistiques et à personne qu'il
utilise un par la france parce que ça ça
justifie aussi notre politique du tout
radar les amendes qui augmente et
s'étirant mais c'est quand même chose
des questions parce que vous regardez
depuis trois quatre ans on n'a pas cessé
d'améliorer la qualité des radars d'en
mettre d'autres de faire dix ou quinze
ans entre flash chaque année en plus et
ça s'améliore pas dans quelle est la
priorité selon vous aujourd'hui si pour
assurer plus de sécurité sur les routes
pour aura à verser à nouveau cette
courbe de 1500 morts par an on quels
sont les les
quelle est la priorité selon vous jouer
surtout les causes et des comportements
mais regarder pourquoi les anglais sont
à moins de 2000 mhz en particulier bon
ils ont effectivement une politique de
radars mais surtout qu'est ce qu'ils ont
gagné
l'alcoolémie chez eux était divisé par
deux dans les dents de l'école dans les
causes d'accidents chez nous elle est
restée stable est toujours stable autour
de 30%
les anglais sont descendus à moitié
pourquoi parce qu en angleterre
quant à l'anglais est pris avec l'alcool
au volant ses voisins ne lui parle plus
il est considéré comme un dangereux
dangereux malfaiteurs oui c'est le cas
donc il ya un rejet de la société en
font aujourd'hui
oui c'est un oui j'étais un bon vivant
oui toute une culture dans tout ça ça se
travaille de sanctions pénales sur le
volet noah d'alcool depuis la culture et
puis les contrôles vous êtes contrôlés
tous les jours pratiquement et d'erreurs
est ce que vous a été contrôlé récemment
avec eux votre taux d'alcoolémie c'est
extrêmement rare voyez donc il n'y a pas
que ça il ya aussi la distraction au
volant il ya la somnolence les routes
c'est que dans 47 % des accidents
il ya un facteur routier qui est est
impliqué en 2012 en bresse qualité la
route en 2012 où tu es champion du monde
pour notre réseau routier en 2016 on est
à la septième place on s'est
complètement dégradés et au maroc
marrant c'est pas le mot mais c'est
curieux de constater que l'accidentalité
recommencent à augmenter quand le réseau
routier se dégrade alors cette décision
n'est pas encore un effectivement on l'a
répété ce sera probablement mardi
d'autres le sont déjà
à commencer par la hausse du prix des
carburants presque 4 centimes par litre
pour l'essence mais surtout plus de 7
centimes pour le diesel avec cette
volonté de rendre le diesel moins
attractif car plus dangereux pour la
santé est plus polluant c'est ce que
disent en tout cas ce que dit le
gouvernement
j'imagine que là aussi vous dénoncez la
technique vous dénoncez cette méthode
d'augmentation des prix sur le sur le
carburant ne croyez pas ces arguments
c'est pas que je crois pas je constate
qu'il ya une rafale de mesures de taxes
qui dès qu'ils arrivent en ce début
d'année
quand vous dites 7,6 centimes ce coin
sur le gazole et 3,8 ce sens vous savez
qu'un centimes d'augmentation sur le
gazon de ses 350 millions dans les
caisses de l'état
donc avec ses autres secteurs et aux
écologistes c'est le arguments prétexte
pour faire virer en fait derrière lui
d'ailleurs si on voulait rééquilibrer il
suffirait de diminuer les taxes sur
l'essence puisque vous avez 60 % taxe
sur le diesel et 65% sur l'essence
la ramenons déjà à 60% les tutos baisser
les taxes
mais là on va ponctionner 3 milliards
dans les poches des automobilistes
en plus on va le pétrole est pas encore
trop cher supposons que le pétrole
augmente
vous allez voir un peu la flambée des
prix rappelez vous en 2012 commencent à
augmenter un petit peu apparemment en
2012 le pétrole était à 120 euros le 120
dollars le baril et aujourd'hui les
verts 60 68 françois hollande on avait
fait un argument de campagne puisque
rappelez vous ça commençait à manifester
dans le pays
y avait il y avait des pompes à 2 euros
je crois une commission de surveillance
des prix du pétrole
un sujet extrêmement sensible
donc ya pas que ça comme os en plus une
bonne nouvelle la prime à la casse qui
pourrissent élargie qui revient pour
2000 euros une bonne nouvelle enfin oui
c'est une bonne chose avait accusé l'ong
nouvelle mais ça fait prochains
véhicules pour 1000 ou 2000 euros vous
avez pas grand chose donc je pense que
si on ponctionne déjà 3 milliard l'an
début d'année plus augmentation des
autoroutes plus d'augmentation des
tarifs de péage plus d'augmentation des
agences donc voyez il ya ces domaines et
à une avalanche de mesures mais en plus
on a déjà annoncé que pendant le
quinquennat on va augmenter de 33
centimes le prix du litre de gazole ça
fait plus de 11 milliards donc si vous
ponctionner use milliards dans les
poches de tonus comment voulez vous
qu'ils aient encore de l'argent pour
acheter un véhicule propre
donc c'est une politique d'impression de
personnes se concertent ou part dans des
décisions mais on ne mesure pas les
effets je voulais vous faire réagir sur
la dernière actualité qui concerne les
automobilistes beaucoup plus local
maintenant avec les pv de stationnement
qui sont gérés par les mairies fini le
tarif unique à 17 euros chaque mêlée
fixe le prix qu'elle souhaite par
exemple montigny le bretonneux ses 25
euros c'est 25 euros pour guyancourt 35
euros dans certains quartiers à
elancourt là aussi ces propositions
seraient faites notamment des jeunes ont
léché à la
l'initiative du maire mais faut savoir
que quand on augmente le forfait postes
de stationnement
ça impacte le coût du stationnement
parce qu'il ne peut pas excéder ce
forfait postes de stationnement
le coût total d'un stationnement à la
journée sur l'argument c'est la rotation
ça permettra d'ailleurs plus tournée
j'avais voiture en centre ville pour
favoriser le commerce local
mais quand vous augmenter encore les
amants peut-être que vous êtes dissuader
les gens de venir en centre-ville
vous avez pas besoin de renvoyer puisque
les sites et d'aimer rambouillet décidé
de baisser son forfait post-it
actionnement il a décidé de réduire un
peu le temps de stationnement de faire
tourner les voitures mais il n'a pas
pénalisé avec des amendes parce qu'il a
un problème pour faire vivre son
centre-ville
donc il a été intelligent sinon moi je
veux encore que les gens puissent venir
en centre-ville délai que la méthode
n'est pas la bonne encore mais là vous
avez des villes on parle toujours des
villes comme beaucoup de monteils à
paris à lyon il ya des villes qui à
linverse soit le saut de 17
il y avait dressé il ya même certaines
qui sont passés en zone bleue vers zéro
voix la voix là parce qu'ils ont dit on
veut faire vivre notre centre ville
voyez donc bien tous les cas de figure
il faut faire appel et on reviendra là
dessus sur le sujet la semaine prochaine
sur tv 78 avec un reportage merci daniel
guerreau d'être réélu sur notre plateau
je rappelle que vous êtes du coup le le
président de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes merci à vous et bon
week-end
on passe tout de suite à l'actualité de
la semaine
l'actualité locale de cette semaine
marquée par les vents violents et le
passage de la tempête
eleanor sur le département des yvelines
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi quatre
mille huit cents foyers étaient privés
d'électricité mercredi matin plus de 160
interventions des pompiers ont été
recensés sur les 24 heures
principalement à cause des chutes
d'arbres retour sur cette nuit et
journée les deux galère avec camille
lambert et patrick jacques de dixmude
depuis 3h ce matin les sapeurs pompiers
des yvelines sont à pied d'oeuvre
la tempe et eleanor a frappé le
département plus 280 agents ont été
mobilisés pour sécuriser les zones à
risque on avait un arbre qui menaçait à
un poste de détente de gaz donc il a
fallu le coupé est de faire tomber
afin de sécuriser les abords pour pas
qu'ils tombent sur des passants sur des
véhicules à rambouillet on est
les douze de personnel de la garde sont
mobilisés on a fait appel à quelques
personnels de repos afin de grossir les
rangs
au total plus de 160 interventions
surtout dans le sud et l'ouest du
département
c'est ici au centre opérationnel
départemental d'incendié et de secours
que les quatre opérateurs coordonne des
événements le principe allemand cdu
dégagements d'arbres ou de branches
d'arbres sur la voie publique
on a aussi des fils électriques tombés
sur la voie publique et après on a des
objets menaçant de tomber en ville ça
peut être des éléments de cheminées des
tuiles des choses comme ça
les sapeurs pompiers ont aussi travaillé
en partenariat avec d'autres services
par endroits la tempête à abîmer les
installations électriques à magny les
hameaux et nady c'est la police
municipale sont intervenus rapidement ou
vers 6h30
un arbre a chuté sur la voie publique en
entraînant avec lui un câble électrique
j'ai été moi déclenchée par par la
brigade de gendarmerie de magny les
hameaux
voilà vingtaine d'habitations peu près
touché par une coupure d'électricité qui
devrait normalement rétablie dans la
journée à la mi journée encore 480
foyers étaient privés d'électricité dans
les yvelines un retour complet à la
normale est prévu dans la soirée
mais la prudence reste de mise même si
la vigilance orange a été levée par
météo france dans le département et pour
être tout à fait exact depuis la
diffusion de ce sujet mercredi soir plus
aucun foyer n'est privé d'électricité
dans le département des yvelines selon
et les 10
l'autre fait marquant de la semaine
c'est la colère des policiers après
l'agression de deux agents dans la nuit
du nouvel an dans le val de marne mardi
une manifestation était organisée pour
dénoncer ces faits une manifestation à
laquelle a participé julien lecat
policiers blinois représentant du
syndicat alliance il était et en direct
par téléphone mardi dans le journal et
dénoncer notamment le manque de moyens
humains extrait op une paire de sandales
interpellé présenter les outils pour lui
en prit en prison ils sont mis en prison
que dans des cas extrêmes et il faudrait
généraliser cette pratique pour que
justement les à 18h01 comment vous
expliquer comment une dizaine de chaînes
projectif et il assure des heures des
policiers ont heureusement sans gravité
on a encore une chance de l'or sur le
département et est un miracle et donc le
vous l'aurez compris je viens au terme
dénoncé le manque de sanctions pénales
contre les agresseurs et non pas le
manque de moyens humains
tout à l'heure nous évoquions les
nouveautés de l'année pour l'automobile
il y à aussi
et nouveauté dans le secteur de la santé
avec est désormais 11 vaccins
obligatoires au lieu de trois pour les
nouveau-nés une mesure qui fait là aussi
polémiques parfois mais qui doit
permettre de mieux lutter contre des
maladies potentiellement mortelles pour
les nouveaux nés
comme l'expliqué sur notre plateau
mercredi renault nadja président du
syndicat des pharmaciens et des yvelines
extraits le problème de la vaccination
c'est c'est que c'est un acte collectif
il faut que qu'il y ait un maximum de
personnes qui se font vacciner
l'om est considère de l'ordre de 90 à 80
ms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
les ars entre 90 et 95% de taux de
vaccination de façon à pouvoir arrêter
une maladie arrêter une maladie à tous
ceux qui défendent une vie bout des
bisounours entre guillemets c'est
souvent des gens qui n'ont pas connu les
grandes maladies parce que les autres se
sont vaccinés parce que les générations
précédentes plomb faits et parce que
aujourd'hui on est autour plus du
nombrilisme et de l'individualisme que
de l'action collective à certains
veulent faire du sport d'autres mieux
manger ou encore passer plus de temps en
famille ce début d'année et le temps
bien sûr des bonnes résolutions
alors quelles sont elles celles des
saint quentinois la réponse au micro de
patrick jacques de dixmude aujourd'hui
pas pris non comme ça je suis sûr de les
tenir pour la santé peut-être faire du
sport ouais mais je me le dis tous les
ans j'espère que cette année ça va
marcher au pas la santé ins et primeurs
bien d'un séduisant plumeau
de prendre plus de temps de
de vivre ma vie de famille parce qu'on
essaie toujours travail travail travail
travail est d'essayer voilà dédié un
petit peu plus les autres parce que je
pense que on est dans un monde on est
très égoïste de continuer à ne rien
faire puisque je suis à la retraite à
sainté la famille et puis et ça me
suffit
mais je les prends tous les jours mes
résolutions alors je vais vous dire je
vois pas pourquoi il faut absolument que
ce soit le 1er janvier vous voyez oui
oui moi je veux rester jeune et beau
absolument pas je ne prends jamais de
résolution seul à manier le meilleure
manière pour ne pas avoir ne pas les
suivre donc pas de résolution et tout va
bien j'espère que 2010 sera aussi bien
que 2017 et aussi bien que 2019 et vous
l'avez entendu dans ce micro trottoir
faire du sport revient souvent comme une
bonne résolution après les nombreux et
riches
repas des fêtes il faut faire fondre les
quelques kilos pris certains ne perdent
pas de temps et se met vite à l'exercice
comme mardi au fitness park de montigny
le bretonneux miquel et demi d'euros les
a filmés dans leur premier effort
reportage ce mardi de janvier à 9h dans
cette salle de fitness de montigny le
bretonneux habille déjà entrain de
transpirer pour tenir l'une de ses
résolutions de l'année 2018 faire du
sport moi non moi je veux faire du
prévenu me tonifier me rappelle
là j'ai prescrit même pas une heure j'ai
dû me de coupe du monde de vélo il
fallait dix minutes de drame art et si
j'ai le temps je perds 25 minutes mais
dans une salle la caf cusack comme adil
sont des dizaines de sportifs dans cette
salle
amateurs ou expérimentés à se lancer
dans cette course pour perdre les 2,3 kg
stockées en moyenne pendant les fêtes
plutôt détox de l'époque ce parce que
grosse prise de prendre plus de poids le
point en soit on l'a on l'a depuis on
évacue on essaie d'évacuer un combat
continu avant soit on sort des repas rne
un peu nous on n'a pas trop envie de se
lever bon on vient quand même ça fait du
bien ça fait du bien au moral de voir
qu'on est qu'on est nombreux à être dans
la même entre guillemets galère un
phénomène qui permet aux salles de sport
d'enregistrer deux à trois fois plus
d'inscriptions en janvier le deuxième
mois le plus rentable après septembre
pour le monde du fitness en fait en
janvier souvent on rencontre des gens
qui ont qui n'ont jamais accédé à une
salle de sport ou qui accéda qu'ils ne
font plus de sport depuis un certain
nombre d'années et qui prennent
conscience justement à ce moment ci de
l'année qu'il faut qu'il se remette à
bouger un peu quoi le mois de janvier
enregistre donc un pic de fréquentation
mais gare à la démotivation
seulement un français sur deux inscrit
juste après les fêtes poursuit le sport
après le mois de mars une pause plus
longue que d'habitude à montigny le
bretonneux en plus des vidanges habituel
des bassins deux fois par an le centre
aquatique du lac est en travaux pour une
quinzaine de jours encore au programme
remplacement des éclairages mais aussi
un nouveau revêtement du sol pour les
sanitaires les détails avec ce reportage
une trêve hivernale qui se prolonge pour
le centre aquatique du lac les bassins
resteront fermés au public jusqu'au 21
janvier
en cause les travaux entamés il ya dix
jours et qui prévoit notamment de
renforcer la sécurité et l'hygiène des
sanitaires avec l'installation d'un
nouveau sol
vasic et légèrement légèrement granit et
donc il va empêcher le
la glissade donc il sera plus sécure
aujourd'hui en avait au niveau des
niveaux des carrelages sur la partie
douche ici donc le sol et l'ensemble des
murs va être revêtue alors qu'en fait
aux partenaires au niveau de la veste
hier ça sera uniquement le sol le
chantier permettra également de
remplacer la totalité des éclairages
dans et en dehors des bassins pour un
système plus économique
l'accès à la piscine est aussi repensé
avec une nouvelle billetterie
enfin les casiers sont remplacés les
monnayeurs sont abandonnés pour plus de
simplicité on va remettre des portes des
casiers plus traditionnel camp fait avec
uniquement le paiement fin ce sera le la
mise d'une pièce pour avoir la caution
les personnes récupéreront ensuite leur
leur leur pièce quand il est le 4e rang
le quasi vides il y aura une clé donc en
fait c'est un système tout à fait
classique coût total des travaux 430
mille euros
ouvert il ya quinze ans le centre
aquatique et fréquenté tous les ans en
moyenne par plus de cent mille personnes
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo retour
de l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tv 78 ha d'ici là restez
connectés et informés grâce à notre site
internet nos réseaux sociaux et notre
application tv et 78 bon week-end à tous
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]